and so in terms of an understanding of  selling if you need to have conviction  you need to have trust trust is going to  come from expertise and some level of  rapport right i think that overarchingly  to help someone sell we just have to ask  the right questions to get someone to  come to the conclusion on their own and  so most sales conversations follow more  or less the same framework if you know  what you're doing otherwise people are  just chasing their tail and trying to  chase a prospect to an outcome that the  prospect doesn't know how like we've had  this conversation a hundred times they  have only had it once we should be the  one knowing how this conversation's  supposed to go right we should also come  in with a massive advantage to how to  have this conversation go the way we  wanted to because we do it on [ __ ]  day